[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHANCHAL CHATTERJEE: My
name is Chanchal Chatterjee.
I work for the Google Cloud.
I'm a cloud AI program manager.
I'll be accompanied
by Adam Hammond, who
is from Quantiphi, on one
of the use cases that we
are going to demonstrate here.
So today, I'm going to talk
about model explainability
for financial services
industry from the perspective
of regulations.
So we have been doing
model explainability
for a long time as a community.
But there has been a bit
of a confusion regarding
who the audience is.
A lot of us who
are developers are
very focused on doing
model explainability
from the standpoint of
understanding the model.
So today, I'm going to take
the perspective away from that.
We're going to talk a bit about
how the financial industry
regulators view model
explainability, which
is the most critical
application of model
explainability in the
financial industry,
and also one of the most
critical use of model
explainability, period.
So moving forward,
we are going to learn
how financial problems, business
critical problems are solved
in the ADL through lending
risk and insurance loss set
to use cases we are
going to look at,
where we'll be explaining
the models from a regulator's
perspective.
All the solutions are built
on the Google Cloud Platform
on the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine
with complex deep
learning models.
We'll also demonstrate how
we improve the accuracy,
but yet we explain the
models for regulators.
And finally, one
of the key pieces
is we are going to convert
some of these models
to a rule-based
solution in order
to augment existing rules.
So if you already have a
rule-based solution that
is completely approved
by the regulators,
then you may not want to
add a completely new model
to the rule.
You'd see a lot of your
financial services customers
ask for additional rules in
order to augment their rules
and make it better so that the
regulatory approval becomes
much easier.
So we'll start with a few use
cases of model explainability
in the financial
services industry.
We'll also talk about why we
want to do model explanations.
We want to talk briefly
about some methods of model
explanation.
I think I'm going to
squeeze those slides
because I don't think that is
very, very relevant for sake
of time.
Then we are going to talk
about types of explanations
that regulators typically want.
And we'll give two examples,
one from lending risk,
the other from insurance loss.
And we'll also talk
about the method
that Google created in order
to augment existing rules.
Can everybody hear me. well?
OK, awesome.
So financial services use cases.
There are many use cases
in financial services
which is of high importance for
model explainability purposes.
So the first one
is credit lending.
This is a use case
we will cover.
The main purpose is to
comply to regulation,
and it's very high importance.
Transaction fraud.
This is where model
explainability
is needed in order to
create transparency.
There are many reasons for
it, but I just highlighted
one or two key reasons.
Anti-money laundering.
Also transparency.
Claims processing.
This is where we
want to automate
the explanations
and the decisions
so that it's all supported
in one transaction.
And we also want to
create transparency.
Investment management,
automated trading
are also very high degree of
use for model explainability
and for automated decisions.
So the two use cases we will
consider, one is lending risk,
the other is insurance
loss prevention.
And Adam will present
insurance loss prevention use
case which he worked on.
Why do model explanation?
So when developers look
at model explanation,
we are typically looking
at model explanation
from the perspective of
understanding the model.
Whereas when the regulators
look at model explanation,
they are trying to increase
their trust in the model.
These are completely
different goals.
This is why I made
this table in order
to make it clear what
the two goals are.
The developers look
at model explanation
to improve performance
of the models,
whereas regulators look
at model explanation
in order to reduce bias
and increase transparency.
Most of our software engineers
would look at model explanation
in order to create
better algorithms,
a better model.
Is this a six-layer ResNet
or a 10-layer ResNet?
Do we do it this
way or that way?
All these differences
are going to come up
in model explanation.
But regulators want to
do model explanation
to comply to regulations.
And the output for software
engineers and developers
for model explanation is
produce a better model, a better
software.
But regulators want to
produce a better report.
So clearly, the two
audiences are very different.
And therefore when you look at
the regulator's perspective,
the entire scope of model
explainability changes.
And how you do
the explainability
and how you report
are very different.
So there's a funny
picture which shows why we
want to do model explanation.
Because we want to
create transparency,
we want to create trust,
we want to create a better
understanding.
And in the US, we
have two guidances.
One is the SR 11-7,
and the OC 2011-12,
which are basically guidance
for model risk management.
But when everybody uses
them, then it almost
becomes mandatory.
GDPR in Europe is
very important.
And there are two articles
that are written, one by SCC
and the other by a large number
of academic and industry people
have written the
article together as
to how to do the governance
of machine learning.
So types and methods
Considering the time, I'm going
to go through fast on this.
And so model interpretation
has two variants.
One is the global,
the other is local.
Those of you who are
practitioners in machine
learning know this difference.
Global is when we take the
entire aggregate of data
and we want to give the
explanation for the model
on the entire
collection of data.
Local is for a
given transaction.
If we are trying to detect
fraud for one transaction that
was considered
fraudulent, you want
to know why you identified
that transaction as fraud
or no fraud.
And it can be a single or a
small group of transactions.
But local explainability
is basically
for a limited number of data.
So in terms of methods,
we saw that there
are over 30 methods
that are used
in the industry, which
cover a wide scope of model
explainability.
I have only identified
the key ones
that are most commonly
used in the industry
and that are most common
and highly prevalent.
So the non-Google ones
that are very common
are LIME, Locally
Interpretable Models.
It's mostly a local model,
I have a brief description.
The second is Anchors, which
is by the same authors.
And SHAP values, which is
very common in the industry.
In terms of the Google
methods, there are two
that I want to highlight.
One is called
integrated gradients.
And that one is very common, and
that has been used very widely
within Google.
I'll describe that in
a little bit of detail.
And the second is called
TCAV, Quantitative Testing
and Concept Activation
Vector, which
is also another
model explainability
tools that Google has created.
So going over these, LIME stands
for Locally Interpretable Model
Agnostic Explanations.
And this is primarily a
local interpretation method,
although there is an extension
to global called SP-LIME.
The key attributes here
is that it generates
data in the vicinity
of the transaction
or the particular data.
And then it fits
the linear model
and explains the linear model.
It treats the features
as uncorrelated.
And the main issue
with LIME, LIME
is excellent in
explaining local models,
doing a local
interpretation of models.
But the problem
here is that it has
to go through the process
of generating synthetic data
and fitting the results to that.
So it creates what we call
a surrogate model, which
is problematic in some cases.
Some regulators will
not accept that.
And secondly, it
takes time to do that.
So if you have a large number
of transactions happening,
a million transactions
per second,
it will be very
difficult to apply
this type of a complex
technique on a transaction
by transaction basis.
The second one is an
innovation over LIME,
which is called
Anchors, which is also
a model agnostic
explanation tool.
So they basically generate logic
and rules around transactions.
And these
high-precision rules are
called anchors, and present
local sufficient conditions
for these predictions.
I have linked the
paper and the GitHub.
It's all open source,
it's by the same authors
that wrote the LIME.
This third one that
is publicly available
is called SHAP
Values, it's Shapley.
It basically does the
model by comparing features
with or without it.
If you take the feature
out, it basically
measures the
sensitivity of a feature
in producing a certain outcome.
What is great about
Shapley is that it produces
the positive and negative
effects on outcomes
for different features.
And we have some
results on that.
And because you have to take
all combinations of features.
If you have, let's say,
a model in which you
have 2,000 features, then taking
different combinations of twos
and threes and four and five
makes millions of combinations.
And therefore it
is very difficult
to go through all
those combinations.
So they make some approximations
called SABAS methods
and other methods.
And what it does is
that it finally creates
an approximate solution.
Nevertheless Shapley
is an awesome method
of doing model explanation and
is widely used in the industry.
And it is also very
fast and accurate
in real-time transactions.
So coming to the Google
methods, the first one
is called integrated
gradients, which are axiomatic
attributions of deep networks.
Now this one is also a
sensitivity type measure.
It is also a local
interpretation tool,
and not geared towards a global
interpretation, although you
can take a whole bunch
of local interpretations,
average them together,
and call it global.
So the basic idea is
you perturb the features
and inspect the
change of the features
on the network's prediction.
This method has been used
in over 20 Google products
internally.
So let's take a visual example
of how this method works.
So here is a picture
of a fireboat
in front of the bridge.
So the model says
there's a fireboat.
So if you look at the far
right picture at this end,
you'll see this is the
picture of the fireboat
and these are the gradients.
So the problem with that is that
the gradients doesn't tell you
anything because it covers
the entire gamut of the bridge
and the boat and the
ocean and everything.
So what do we do
in this method is
we take a baseline
picture, which is
a near dark picture beforehand.
And then we look at
the gradients that
come out of that
picture, and we see
some remnants of the bridge.
Then as we change
the picture intensity
from almost dark to
the full intensity,
different gradients emerge.
And as you've progress through
this different intensity
of the picture, and as you
see these different gradients
as you integrate through
these gradients, then, voila,
the explanation comes out.
And you get a beautiful
picture of the gradients
that are relevant to
the fireboat itself.
And that's how the integrated
gradient method works.
And we also found
that the gradients
are most relevant during
the transition phase rather
than the full featured image.
And this is an internal paper
published and available.
So next one is called TCAV.
This is an innovation over
the axiomatic methods.
This creates boundaries
of different features
in order to judge the
sensitivity of the feature's
effects on the outputs.
So these are some of the methods
we have for model explanation
that are fairly common.
So next, let's look at
the types of explanations
that regulators
will be looking for.
The first one that
is most common
is the importance of
the different features.
How are the different
features important?
So if you label the features
one through nine or 10,
then you see that
certain features
have a higher importance.
The second thing you
also want to look
at the standard deviations
of those features.
That is, it's not
important just to be
able to take the
average importance,
but also how does
that importance
vary from sample to sample.
Like if you have an
important such as point,
let's say, 31, but
the standard deviation
is 20, which means that the
importance of that feature
varied widely over the samples.
So you want to also look
at the standard deviations.
The second is the positive
and negative contributions
of features.
That is, if certain inputs had
a positive effect on the outcome
and certain inputs had a
negative effect on the outcome,
so those are the
two important things
that a regulator would want.
The other two important
things are joint contributions
and inputs.
So let's say you had two inputs.
One was let's say
the loan amount,
and the second one was
the income of the person.
How does the loan
amount and income
relate to each other in terms
of the risk of credit lending?
So in those two examples,
we'll take some examples
of how that happens.
And also we want to see how does
an input increase the outcome
and how does an input
decrease the outcome.
And then fourthly, how
does the different samples
affect the outcome,
the different inputs,
vary from sample to sample
in increasing and decreasing
the outcome.
So let us go through
the first example,
and then I'll turn it over to
Adam for the second example.
Loan risk prediction.
This is a credit to risk
and customer lifecycle value
prediction problem.
The data came from Freddie
Mac's single family home loan.
The ML-based solution is
using user behavior patterns.
And we are predicting
the user risk, which
is the loan delinquency risk.
So this is an example that
is very relevant to cases
like student loan delinquencies,
which has been announced
has gone to 9.1% in some cases.
The US is facing student
loan repayment crises.
It can be repurposed to market
loans, student loans, auto
loans, credit card
loans, personal loans.
The partner on this
project is Pluto7.
So we basically considered
four classes of outcomes.
And one is safe.
We say that the creditor
has been very safe lender,
or has been very safe
to lend to the person.
Second is moderate safe.
And the percentages shows
that how much of the data
was in each of these categories.
As you can see, very risky, we
have very, very little data.
So this is a very
unbalanced situation
where we have large amount
of very safe lenders.
And a lot of these
financial services examples,
we have very unbalanced data.
That is, one outcome has a
very small amount of data.
So we took three sets of data
and we build multiple models
on that.
And the results were very good.
We used deep learning
networks, we used XGBoost,
we used Random Forest, and
we used naive Bayes methods.
So by using all these
different algorithms,
we came up with a
very good result
in which the case 1 is safe
and case 2 is moderate safe.
The third one is moderate
risky, and the fourth one
is very risky.
Obviously, you want to catch
the last two very accurately.
And we have 99% accuracy
in the last two,
the class 2 and 3, which
is moderate risk and risky.
And this was a
fantastic result we got.
So going to model
explanation on this problem,
I took the top six
inputs that I'm going
to use to explain the models.
The first one is
recency, which is
the number of months
ago the customer
had a recorded delinquency.
i stands for number of months.
Frequency, how
often the customer
had a recorded loan delinquency
value of which category,
1, 2, 3.
Recency i is the category
delinquency value
with a 0, 1, 2, 3.
0 is most safe, and
3 is most risky.
Credit score.
We all know what that is.
Loan to value.
Loan to value means what
is the value of the asset,
and what is the amount of
loan they took on the asset.
Let's say your home
is worth $200,000,
and you borrowed $100,000,
then your loan to value is 50%.
So the original unpaid
balance of the mortgage
and the original interest
rate on the mortgage.
Again, I can take any one
of these four values-- safe,
moderate safe, mod
risky, and risky.
So then going through
those four examples
that I gave what
the regulators look.
First one is the
future importance.
Second is the positive
and negative contributions
of inputs.
So we found out that
recency score of 2
was one of the highest
important features, which
means that if you are
moderately risky before,
you have a high propensity
of becoming risky.
And then recency
score of safe means
also was a very high
predictor of safety.
And therefore recency score of
0 and 1 were also very high.
Unpaid balance is also one
of the high important inputs
in predicting the outcome.
But that doesn't tell
you the whole story.
I told you that recency of 2 is
probably a predictor of risky,
recency of 0 is probably
a predictor of safe.
So we also want to know
which one of these inputs
had a positive
contribution on the outcome
and a negative contribution.
Which increased
the outcome, which
decreased the outcome, right?
Which predicted risky,
which predicted safe?
So that's important to know.
So we found that signed
early increased the risk.
So the red line shows that if
that particular input increased
the risk, and if any other
input decreased the risk.
So you want to know which inputs
had what degree of contribution
towards a positive outcome
or a negative outcome.
And also to what degree,
like signed early
had a huge contribution
in increasing the risk.
And same as the discount.
Whereas the quantity,
how many loans they took,
had a very small contribution
in decreasing risk.
The second thing is to look at
the correlations of features.
The left chart,
the vertical bars
are 15-year mortgage, 20
year, 25, and 30 year.
And you can see, 15-year
loans have higher risks
than 30-year loans.
It's a deduction
you can make out
of this original long term
versus the original loan.
If you look at the term of
the loan and the riskiness,
the blue means it lowered
the risk, whereas red
means it increased the risk.
So 15 year had a high
degree of risk lowering
and a high degree
of risk increase.
So it had a wide range of
contribution towards the risk.
On the right side, you
can see California loan.
I have results on
many other cities.
So whenever I go
make presentation,
I can switch to Illinois, to
New York, to other places.
But here, we are
talking in California.
So you can say California
properties have a lower risk
because even though it makes a
negative contribution on risk,
which means that it
increases the risk.
But the increases
of a smaller amount
compared the range of values,
the intensity is smaller.
Whereas any other
state, the risk increase
of a much higher
intensity and the decrease
is of a smaller value.
So clearly, there
is a bigger risk--
any other state but California.
And I don't know if
that is true or not,
but this data shows that.
So that's a great example.
So welcome, Adam.
He's going to talk about the
second use case, insurance loss
prevention.
Please.
Thank you.
ADAM HAMMOND: Thanks, Chanchal.
So the use case that I wanted
to speak about today to you all
was insurance loss prevention.
So here what we had done
with a particular property
and casualty carrier
is they wanted
to take a look at
the loss likelihood
of their particular policies.
So there are really
three elements
that you can consider when
you're factoring losses.
So that's the frequency
that happens, so
whether it will occur or not.
The severity of it, so how
much will that loss be.
And the timing of it.
For this particular
carrier in line
of business and that carrier,
the crucial thing for them
was whether or not
a loss occurred,
because the majority
of those losses
were greater than the premiums,
so they didn't necessarily
care about the severity.
Anytime you had a loss,
it would be an issue.
To recreate this analysis, so
the data would be a little bit
different here, I took
some open source data
that's available through
Google data set search.
And it was Iowa Property and
Casualty losses data set.
It also contains a
little bit of information
from the surrounding states.
So whereas Chanchal chose an
active state that we're in,
California, I chose one
that don't visit too often
for conferences in Iowa.
But our solution was
ML-based, and that's
from policy information.
And then one component
that we added to that
was crime score details.
So based on the location
of a particular policy,
the crime score
could be different.
And what we wanted
to do is to be
able to predict that policy's
likelihood of resulting
in a loss.
Some examples in terms of
why frequency is important,
just linked to couple
articles in the top right.
And then different
examples of insurance
that are out there where some
similar analysis can be done
is in property casualty,
which really focused on here.
But also we've seen it in
auto, professional lines,
and health insurance as well.
So first getting into the
data preparation results.
So here we didn't quite have
the issues with class imbalance
to the same level as
Chanchal's use case.
But what we saw was that
the majority of policies
resulted in not having a loss.
And then about 40% resulted in
having a loss from that data
set.
Some additions that we
made were a loss flag.
So in the data set, if
you look this up online,
it will just contain the
value of a particular loss.
So we wanted to create a 1, 0,
since we're really just looking
for the likelihood
and not the severity.
We added some crime
score index information.
So again, based on
the location, which
we randomized based on
the state that they're in,
we just added crime
score index data to that.
The results that we
were able to generate
by running just a pretty simple,
straightforward random forest
here was an AUC of 0.91.
And the way that we compared
it was with the false positive
rate and true positive rate.
Basically, at smaller levels
of that false positive rate,
you want to have a higher
true positive rate.
Meaning those that you
forecast or predict as positive
are actually going
to be positive.
Those that we say that will have
a loss actually do have a loss.
So when we look at that at
individual threshold levels,
if we look at the false
positive rate of 1%,
we can see that the
true positive rate there
that we have is 40%.
And we expect that to
increase over time.
So at 10% of the
false positives,
we'd have 78% of
the true positives.
So anything really above an
equal false positive and true
positive rate would indicate
a well performing model.
When we go through
this process, there
are a couple of different ways
that we make it interpretable.
Some of these we've seen before.
So I'll gloss over
them at a high level.
But the first thing we do, often
before we even start modeling,
is look at the
feature correlations.
So understand
whether or not there
may be a positive or negative
effect on the outcome,
as well as if any
features have correlations
with each other as your
independent features.
So what this will
do is shed light
on the different
relationships that we see.
So you can easily see
a plot of the data
if I go down the diagonal axis
from top right to bottom right.
Then we can see the
scatter plots, which
would be between two fields.
So if I look at these
second row, first column,
basically that's
showcasing my scatter plot
for premiums written
versus taxes paid.
So we'd expect some alignment
or correlation there.
And then on the
right-hand side of it,
so if I look at the
first row, second column,
I'm seeing the correlation
between those two,
between premiums
written and taxes paid.
So this is often how we begin to
wrap our minds around the data
that we take a look at.
The second thing that we do
is once we perform the model
and we want to understand
a little bit more
on that global
interpretability front
is we look at the
feature importance.
So here what we're
just looking at
is the mean decrease
in Gini, and we're
able to see that the
important features here
are crime index, premiums
written, and line of insurance.
Now as Chanchal
pointed out earlier,
a great thing to add to this
is going to be your variance.
So you can tell sample by
sample how this changes.
We didn't really have a
high variance in this one,
so didn't necessarily
add them to the visual.
But this also needs
to be combined
with some exploratory analysis
to understand the direction.
So just because we know
a feature is important,
so if my crime
index is important,
to be able to see if I have
a loss or not, from logic
here I think we can tell
which direction it is.
But you'd also want some
exploratory data analysis
to say a higher crime
score would indicate
a higher likelihood of loss.
So this in isolation
doesn't do well,
but in combination with some
exploratory data analysis
can act as a way to
interpret models.
The next one that
we wanted to look at
was again more on that local
interpretability front.
And the ones that we
use most frequently
when we're looking at problems
that are in tabular structures
are going to be LIME
and going to be SHAP,
as Chanchal already mentioned
what those two things are.
But here rather than looking
at an overall level, one thing
that we've found useful
in displaying information
to customers is looking at
it at the observation level.
So typically we may
see this in customer
churn prediction
problems where they're
trying to identify for
a particular customer
the specific reasons why
that customer might churn.
So rather than
looking at all data
points across all
features, we look
at one specific observation
across the features.
So it might be for
this individual person
that the written premium and
crime index are increasing
their likelihood
of churn, the taxes
paid for it might be decreasing
their likelihood of churn,
versus their industry that
the property and casualty then
was assigned to increasing it,
and the location decreasing it.
But understanding that
on an individual level,
and then it might change from
observation to observation
when I'm looking at
both LIME and SHAP
is extraordinarily helpful.
All right, thanks, Chanchal,
now I'll hand it back to you
to convert to deep Learning.
CHANCHAL CHATTERJEE:
Thank you, Adam.
Such an excellent result,
the two use cases.
So once again, in each
of these use cases
we identified four
things that are
very important to regulators.
One is, which
inputs are important
and what is the intensity
and the variance of that.
Secondly, how do the inputs
correlate to the outcomes,
contribute to the
outcomes in a positive way
and a negative way.
That is, which one
increases the outcome, which
decreases the outcome.
In Adam's case, it
was loss prediction.
In the example I took with
Pluto7 was in loan delinquency
prediction.
That's the outcome.
So which inputs make it larger,
which inputs make it smaller.
The third thing, how
do different inputs
correlate with each other in
contributing to the outcome.
So for example, you might find
that a certain amount of loan
may not matter if it is
taken from certain banks.
So maybe the large banks
control the loan industry.
We didn't find that
result, but say that we
could find a result like that.
It does not matter what the
amount is as long as you take
it from these banks, right?
Something you see significant
results like that.
And sometimes you
see how relationships
between you and the banking
makes the difference.
And we sometimes find those
as important criteria.
So the correlation
between different inputs,
the person like the lender, and
the person who is lending to,
the relationship matters.
So the correlations
demonstrate that.
And lastly is how do
these different inputs
change from sample to sample
are very important things.
And finally, I'm going to show
a very strong and innovative
research that came
out of Google Research
by two folks, Nicholas
Frosst and Geoffrey Hinton.
Geoffrey Hinton is obviously
very, very, very well known.
Won the Turing Award
just a few days ago.
Nicholas is a student.
And we thought that this is
a very significant result
in order to do what is called an
augmenting of an existing rule
by creating a soft
decision tree.
Is my audio still working?
Let's say you've built a complex
model, a deep learning model.
But a lot of the
time, your regulators
will not allow you
to use that model.
They will say, distill
it down to a few rules
that you can add to an existing
solution that's already there
which has passed regulation.
We want to add more rules
to that, that's what we do.
So a typical method
to solve this problem
would be to take that
deep learning network--
here's the input,
here's the output.
And take that same
input and output
and create a random
forest or a decision tree.
What happens is that the
results drastically drop.
And let's say your complex
deep learning model did 99%.
All of a sudden the
decision tree does 80%.
So there have got to be a
solution in between where
do you take that deep learning
model and convert it to rules,
but you do not lose
the performance to that
drastic a degree, that you come
up with something in between.
And this result is that, that it
produces the results somewhere
in between.
It basically takes the
deep learning model
and tries to understand what
the inner workings of the models
are, what are the
gradients at each layer.
So that you can take that
make it into a decision tree.
This particular
picture on the right
is from a game
called Connect Four.
And so the main idea of
the soft decision tree
is to augment existing
rules, find features
that have significant influence
on the input, on the outcome,
and create a human
interpretable rule.
So a binary decision tree
that has learned filters
at each of the
nodes is basically
a multinomial
distribution function.
And then when you do
a stochastic gradient
on that, which is
the back propagation
algorithm by which you learn
a deep learning network,
then you use a
equation like that
when you sum a multinomial
distribution over all layers
of the network, and then you're
running a stochastic gradient
descent.
So what we do is that
we took the MNIST data.
And then we learned the filters
can be understood by a person.
And then errors can
be easily understood.
And then the branch numbers
indicate the potential
for the classification.
This is classification
of digits.
Then the leaf number indicates
the final classification.
So what they did
in their research,
they took this complex decision,
the convolution neural network.
And they learned layer by
layer what the decision was,
and they converted that
to a decision tree.
By that, they got
to 96% accuracy
in solving it that way.
So this chart demonstrates
on three examples.
One is MNIST, the other is
Connect Four, and the letters.
So the deep network gave
very high accuracy, like 99%.
Letters, 95%.
Connect Four is 87.7%.
But when you fit
a decision tree,
then the performance
drops drastically.
You can see 87% going to 78%.
So anywhere from 5% to
20%, in some instances.
As you can see, a
95% drop to 78%.
But using this
decision tree approach
to the soft decision
tree approach,
we got a result in between.
So we created a human
readable rule, which
you can use to augment
your existing rules,
satisfy the regulations.
But yet you don't have as
bad a performance as fitting
a simple decision tree.
So that's all I have.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]